we brothel in every day we Brussels in
every day we Brussels in I hate Brussels
sprouts I hate Brussels sprouts
I think Brussels sprouts are disgusting
and terrible I went out to dinner with
my friends from high school a few months
ago and they forced me to try Brussels
sprouts again it was covered in like
garlic and bacon and it was still
disgusting being a vegetarian I think
people often assume that I'm typically
always down for Brussels sprouts any
time I tell people it so is this like
shocked reaction I haven't really given
it a fair shot but I don't know if I'm
gonna give it a fair shot today either
my name is Ross Panetta currently the
junior sous chef at pig and cow
I am happy healthy latina aka chef
yachty and I'm the plant-based people
chef
I heard we have some picky eaters with a
vegetable Brussels sprout I think I have
a little bit of a bad rep right here
coming to bring the brussels to the
hustle let's get these haters out here
and turn them into numbers we hear you
might have some vegetables that are not
your favorite I've not had one single
Brussels sprout that I've ever known
terrible do they smell like what garbage
a little baby cabbage I don't like I
don't like cabbage I don't like Davis I
am like beyond picky but it's all in my
head it's all about texture sort of and
temperature what are some of the ways
you've eaten Brussels sprouts before
I've eaten it like the really gross way
where you just like microwave them and
then put it out there wait No
well what are some flavors that you like
what makes you happy I like spicy food
okay I love crunchy things
I'm like I savory over a sweet kind of
person over sweet are you a strict
vegetarian I eat seafood back okay it's
gonna be already may the odds be ever in
our
I love to mix in sofrito Caribbean
flavors lots of spices and seasonings
that our contestants said that they love
so I'm gonna mix that with something
that they absolutely hate which is
Brussels sprouts and see if we can hide
it but celebrate and tuck it at the same
time I'm making a shaved Brussels slaw
with some red onions and then I'm making
a Brussels sprout slider and old bay
Brussels chippies a lot of what people
don't like is like the texture and the
shape so by using this mandolin here
I've already deconstructed the shape and
we're gonna make it right let's grab I'm
making a Brussels sprout salad so it's
practically deep-fried Brussels sprouts
with some cilantro mint some chili lime
dressing like Southeast Asian style
traditionally we use pork jowl which is
right under here but today I'm going to
be using bacon and pancetta so I'm just
trying to bring all these flavors so
that people can understand that Brussels
sprouts are not that bad and I
understand that we do have a vegetarian
in our panel of judges but you don't
have to put in any meat in this salad
which is actually really good so you can
stay healthy and enjoy Brussels sprouts
at the same time I'm deep-frying the
Brussels sprouts just plain canola oil
that takes away some of the bitterness
when you hit it with a salt acid and all
the herbs it really brings out the best
flavor a few fossils ooh I brought my
Caribbean flavors with my homemade adobo
and sofrito inside of my panko then I
have my American flavors with my slider
and my Brussels sprout fries and I'm
bringing the Asian flavors with what I'm
doing to the shrimp I'm bringing some
garlic some honey some soy sauce some
ginger hey Pam that was a technical
cooking term
[Music]
[Applause]
this is the America meets Caribbean
Brussels sprouts every day we hustle in
Brussels and plate you got your Brussels
sprout slider your old bay Brussels
sprout chippies a miso maple butter
sauce a shaved slaw and some jalapeno in
your face I just pretty much made a
fried Brussels sprout salad kept its
healthy station with the flavors with
chili lime dressing for my
non-vegetarian homies I put some bacon
and pancetta lardons this is toasted
rice powder there's a little bit more
extra for there and we are done
[Music]
and I don't even really taste the
Brussels sprout in the paddy I said I
like crunchy she listened to me she made
an autocracy I tried to be the people
chef it's sweet at a restaurant someone
put this down I'd be like hell no I'm
not touching this but it has really nice
flavor and really nice spice it's like
sweet and savory kind of mixed together
exactly what I was going digger first
dish so good delicious I love the
texture of it especially the chippies on
the side I thought it was great the
second dish when you put that down on
the table I was like mm cut the pressure
was on the cameras were rolling so I
took a bite and I'm so glad that I did
that's when blinders on because I don't
want to make anybody feel bad the second
dish is my favorite as vegetarian I'm
always open to different slider options
and this was delicious and the chips on
the side were a really nice added bonus
the second dish I also loved as well I'm
a big fan of vegetables and salads and
everything while both were incredible
the creativity and of the first dish
really struck a chord with me that's my
favorite slider is something I really
like and so to do like a Brussels sprout
take on it was like really cool for me
and then the salad and really shocked me
because I was like looking at a full
Brussels sprout and I was you expect me
to put this in my mouth but the flavors
were amazing they were like the spices
all mixed together and they were like
savory and sweet but I think I have to
go with the salad I was literally eating
a Brussels sprout just straight up and
it was amazing and I was shocked I'm
glad we got to change you guys's mine
get some Brussels fingers going here the
chef Ross do we hustle for these
Brussels it's all in the muscle
[Music]